she fled the nazis as a child and rose
to become one of the most powerful women
in the history of the us government
madeleine albright america's first
female secretary of state has died at
the age of 84. rosalind jordan now looks
back on her life and career
without any mental health madeleine
albright made history when in 1997
she became the first woman to serve as
u.s secretary of state discharge the
duties of the office discharge the
duties of the office on which i am about
to enter on which i'm about to enter
albright wielded her power in direct and
controversial ways enforcing the u.n
economic embargo against iraq despite
iraq's present weakness the future
threat has not been erased
iraq's behavior and intentions must
change before our policies can change
otherwise we will allow the scorpion
that bit us once to bite us again
pushing u.s allies to back a military
strike on iraq in 1998 because of saddam
hussein's refusal to let u.n weapons
inspectors into the country we have said
many times that we prefer
to have a diplomatic solution
but we need to resolve this problem
and we have also said
that we will take what necessary means
in order to achieve those two objectives
and supporting the u.s bombing of kosovo
in 1999 to protect bosnian muslims what
was happening in the former yugoslavia
it was a far away place with people with
unpronounceable names and i felt that we
did have to do something and of what
people what i'm proudest of is what we
did in bosnia and what later when i was
secretary of state we did in kosovo
madeleine corbell was born in the former
czechoslovakia in 1937
the daughter of a diplomat the corbell
family fled to the u.s after communists
took power in prague in 1947
after university corbell married joseph
albright and raised a family
at age 39 she completed her phd and
launched her foreign policy career
including serving on the national
security council under president jimmy
carter and serving as u.s ambassador to
the united nations under president bill
clinton today we begin to cleanse the
hatred that has torn apart the former
yugoslavia albright was criticized for
pushing a tough policy on iraq that led
to children dying of hunger and medicine
shortages we have heard that a half a
million children have died is the price
worth it
i think this is a very hard choice but
the price we think the price is worth it
and albright failed to broker peace
between the palestinians and israelis
she also couldn't stop north korea from
selling ballistic missiles to other
countries in her later years albright
set up a consultancy taught future
diplomats and became something of a pop
culture figure in the united states
she wrote a book about the messages
behind the brooches she wear i am so
sorry to keep you waiting and albright
appeared twice on a tv drama about a
fictional secretary of state
more than anything madeleine albright
will likely be remembered for holding an
unvarnished view of the world and
willing to confront challenges head on